er hat jetzt gerade gesagt in der
sitzung ralf armin laschet gerade eben
im bundesvorstand zitat ich bin bereit
die kandidatur zu übernehmen viele haben
in den vergangenen tagen zur sache
gesprochen und ich ermutige jeden das
hier erneut zu tun was bedeutet dieser
satz von amys asche zunächst einmal
unterstreicht er
er will kanzlerkandidat bleiben also all
diejenigen die gedacht haben dass er
vielleicht doch sagt naja vielleicht
kannst du sogar machen das hat erst mal
abgeräumt er will kanzlerkandidat
bleiben oder sagt leute okay wenn ihr
etwas zu sagen habt dann sagt es hier
und jetzt ja muss natürlich sich stark
geben er muss an seiner position fest
halten alles andere wäre ja ein
einknicken
aber er fordert auch ganz klar auf jetzt
zu sagen wer für ihn ist jeder der jetzt
schweigt setzt sich zumindest im zweifel
aus im ernstfall nicht für ihn stimmen
zu wollen ich glaube an die nation wird
heute kein formelles votum herbeiführen
denn das wäre sicherlich nicht ganz
einfach und der vorstand wird ein eher
diffuses meinungsbild wiederum zustande
bringen und nicht formal abstimmen und
dahinter kann man sich dann jeder zeit
verstecken das ist überhaupt kein
problem da rauszukommen
aber armin laschet hat das heft des
handelns in der hand er hat den vorstand
einberufen er sagt sagt mir jetzt werden
wir unterstützt da wird es einige geben
vor allem die granden der partei volker
bouffier aus hessen wolfgang schäuble
als bundestagspräsident
aber es werden auch etliche schweigen
und das wird ein signal sein von dem
erstmaligen ralf reicht nach einer woche
debatte reicht dann noch schweigen muss
man dann jetzt nicht auch als cdu
funktionär der armin söder will
aufstehen und dem vorsitzenden ins
gesicht schauen in die augen schauen und
sagen ich möchte das ist markus söder
wird das wäre sicherlich unter
journalistischen gesichtspunkten und der
inszenatorischen dramatik wäre das eine
tolle nummer aber so funktioniert
politik nicht zumal in der union auch
der mut nicht mit kellen ausgegeben ist
man versucht halt gesichtswahrende
rauszukommen und man hat sich im vorfeld
schon in der letzten woche verständigt
dass diejenigen die gegen armin laschet
sind durch schweigen
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren